DIMMs take the white house that's the
focus of tonight's angle serious times
require serious leadership and the last
few days have furnished us with ample
reasons for why Democrats should get
nowhere near the Oval Office well as the
border crisis deepens with the DHS
reporting a near record 100,000 border
apprehensions in April this is what Jill
Biden's thinking
[Music]
that's why
[Music]
more clinics health care for illegals
why should anyone be surprised after all
it was the obama-biden White House that
rewarded hundreds of thousands of
illegals with daca work status according
to federal data obtained by Breitbart
news US taxpayers already pay about a
quarter of a billion dollars annually to
provide health care to illegals who are
in ice custody but that's nothing when
compared to the 17 billion yes with a B
that Americans pay out in medical care
to illegals living inside the United
States yet by the solution is to
apparently dole out additional coverage
at clinics to illegals and then make the
trip even more attractive to them across
the border and that means saddling you
with the bills when Biden was VP illegal
immigration numbers were staggering now
remember the unaccompanied minors crisis
in 2014 was a nightmare but five years
later the former VP is well blame
shifting
no they're coming because Obama Biden
did nothing to change the asylum laws
and because today's Democrats in the
house refused to do that as well now as
you know this past week I saw firsthand
at the Del Rio and Eagle Pass sectors of
Texas how overwhelmed our very
professional and hardworking border
patrol is and the processing centers
there essentially have become daycare
centers we've got to pretty much try and
get a hold of every type of formula we
can so that we can get that child to
take food because they usually get your
malnourished if they aren't already sick
with some kind of respiratory virus we
have to remove from the field patrol to
fill bottles and the good thing is many
of us are parents so we know how to
change diapers and we know how to feed
bottles but we do not have a staff
specifically for them it is a complete
and utter scandal and it's a disgusting
abdication of congressional
responsibility now while Dimmit
Democrats actually deny this reality
Trump has taken serious steps to address
the border crisis his plan to send
asylum seekers back to Mexico as they
await hearings was originally blocked by
a federal district court but this week
the Ninth Circuit ruled that the policy
can continue at least temporarily that's
good news they're also training 200
Border Patrol agents to do enhanced
Asylum screenings right at the border
but expect a court challenge eventually
to that as well an immigration plan is
going to be released we hear next week
by the administration and from what I
hear I'm gonna like some things in it
and probably not like some other things
in it but at least the president is
facing the reality of what has to be
done head-on and he knows he needs
Democrat votes to do it and while
brother Joe wants to extend health
rights to citizens look at this pic I
snapped in Houston the other night we
were leaving the studio Raymond Arroyo
saw this and he said let's stop those
are homeless America
on the streets of the city and it was
pouring rain there's a huge flood in
Houston yesterday it was terrible
weather and it started the night before
so my question looking at this it was
heartbreaking
shouldn't we be caring for our own
citizens before we take responsibility
for the indigent citizens of foreign
countries and speaking of foreign
countries on the trade front no
president in decades has been as dogged
or tough and negotiating deals that are
fair to American businesses and workers
as Trump under the previous
administration the United States lost
nearly a quarter of a million
manufacturing jobs you remember that
they let other countries raid our
factories steal our jobs and robbed us
blind other than that they were very
nice they allowed China to freely loot
our economy plunder our intellectual
property and target our industries for
destruction that's what was happening
Trump has been relentlessly negotiating
a trade deal with China he's driving a
hard bargain Beijing had attempted to
delay the negotiation schedule in DC
this week once the tariffs went on the
up the meeting it was supposed to take
place originally on Thursday then about
five weeks ago they said how about
Friday how about next week I said what's
this all about and I said that's okay
let's don't worry about it let's take in
a hundred billion a year and we put the
tariffs on we made the statement and
then they upped the meeting how about
let's go back to Thursday I'm
representing the USA and he's
representing China and we're not going
to be taking advantage of any more we're
gonna find out about China tonight and I
think in the end you're gonna be very
impressed
well while Trump is engaging the Chinese
and holding out for the best deal for
America rambling Joe is once again in
denial China is going to eat our lunch
come on man they can't even figure out
how to deal with the the they that the
fact that they have this great division
between the
China Sea and the mountains in the East
I mean in the West I mean I you know
they're not bad folks folks but guess
what competition for us oh my god it's
just actually it would be sad if it
weren't so infuriating and basically
it's just embarrassing Obama and Biden
stood by while China continued to cheat
and steal us blind in the united states
and if joe ever took the levers of power
again it would be back to business as
usual with China
in other words China wins we lose what
about the other 2020 Democrat hopefuls
well if you think they have better ideas
you'd be wrong
take mayor Pete last seen in a Vogue
magazine shoot with all his vast
experience in international trade he's
weighing in on the China negotiations as
well China often works in terms of 20
year plans I'm not sure this president
thinks beyond his next tweet and it
shows in our policies when it comes to
trade we need fair trade look there's
currency manipulation intellectual
property theft there's all kinds of bad
behavior going on on the Chinese side if
we want to reverse that reduce that then
there has to be some sense that we're
going to come to the table and negotiate
something better
not just lobbying tariffs over the fence
aside the fact that one does not lob
tariffs and there is no fence what does
he think Trump and Bob white hyzer is
USTR the entire trade team have been
doing all this time reading Vogue
magazine team Trump successfully
negotiated our trade deal with South
Korea he did NAFTA over and is now on to
the crown jewel of China and it's gonna
be hard it might not be possible and the
only reason by the way China is in town
tonight
Trump's tariffs there we have been booed
at judge booth edge edge they say edge
edge he's got a great chance says they
help me Greg he'll be great representing
us against President Xi of China that'll
be great
be great I want to be in that room I
want to watch that one well for the sake
of the country let's hope it's a scene
none of us ever see like the country
can't afford another Democrat in the
Oval Office right now especially not
from this radicalized version of the
Democrat Party they're not only bereft
of policies that work that are practical
they don't even recognize the verifiable
threats that are bearing down on us or
the fact that this economy is on fire
and that's the angle